[تصفيق]
بدايه بجد انتم حاجه اتشرف وانا مبسوط قوي
قوي
ان انا اكون حاجه قد كده في ايفنت ما شاء
الله عليكم قد كده يعني
طيب ندخل في الموضوع على طول
حد فيكم يعرف تلات اماكن دول موجودين فين
في مصر
طيب
بس قبل
مسرح قصه الاماكن والجانب
انا حابب الاول ان انا اتكلم عن حاجه
تانيه وارجع بيكم كده سبع سنين اللي خلتني
اكشن يكون باحكي سكيتشر
من سبع سنين كنت لسه داخل جامعه وابتديت
ان انا افكر كان عندي اصحاب كتير من سوريا
وكان كل حاجه بتيجي في دماغي عن سوريا
كانت دايما عن
وبصراحه بسبب معرفتي من اصحابي قوي كنت
كنت قوي ان انا اعرف اكثر عن البلد
دوستي ما كانش في اي حاجه ثانيه بصراحه
بس
انبهرت قوي لما عرفت ان
اللي احنا كنا بنشوفه وقتها على التلفزيون
او على السوشيال ميديا
وده بصراحه خلاني كده افكر طب
مدام سوريا بالحلاوه دي بس انا
كنت مفكر ان هي مش كويسه او فيها مشاكل بس
بس اكل في سايت ثاني يعني ما كنتش مكتشفه
اوكي والموضوع كان واقف علي انا كان واقف
على من عندي انا ان انا بس اتيك ستاب
وجيت بعد كده افكر طب واي نوت ان انا اخد
بس السيف دي تبقى في بلدي وايه اكشن
فبرده حصل نفس الحاجه بس هنا شويه مختلفه
لانه على فكره
وساعتها كنت لسه برضه اللي هو عايز اكتشف
اكتر وعايز اعرف اكتر عن بلدي واعرف اكثر
عن
الاماكن اللي فيها لانه اتاكدت انه
الاماكن اللي احنا عارفينها كلها لا اكيد
في فيس تاني انا ما اعرفوش
فدي حاجه خلتنا ان احنا نبدا
وكل الجول بتاعنا ان احنا عايزين ان احنا
نريدي فاين او ننقل اماكن الموجوده في مصر
بس بطريقه مختلفه مكناش شفناها قبل كده
واحده بواحده ابتدينا كميه تكبر اونلاين
وقلنا ان احنا
كمان كنا حابين انه لا احنا عايزين نجو
ونشوف الاكسي اس دي عامله ازاي ونخلي
الناس كمان نشجعها تروح الاماكن دي فاحنا
كنا اكشن عايزين نبقى احنا اللي
بتاعتنا
ان احنا قلنا احنا عايزين نروح بورسعيد
عايزين نجرب اول مره كنا هنطلع بره
القاهره طلعنا في بورسعيد وعايزين نشوف
فرصه سعيده هتبقى عامله ازاي احنا شفنا
صوره او اثنين على انستجرام كلمنا حد من
صحابنا هناك
بورسعيد اللي ممكن نعمله في يوم واحد
وبصراحه بمجرد ما روحنا احنا كنا مبهورين
والصوره اللي انتم شايفينها في النص دي ده
مسجد السلام وقناه السويس
ولو قلت لكم ان الناس اللي كانوا هناك
الفورسعيديه كانوا مستغربين ان احنا بنصور
اللي هو انتم بتصوروا ايه انتم يعني كنا
كلنا مبهورين وشايفين المنظر والقناه
السويس ومسجد السلام اللي بنشوفها في
التلفزيون
واحنا لان احنا ما كناش نعرف انه في حاجه
زي كده اصلا موجوده غير بس حاجات بسيطه
قوي
فرحنا في بورسعيد عدينا بالمعديه لو حد
راح هناك يعرف ان انت لازم عشان تروح من
بورسعيد لفؤاد لازم تعدي بالمعديه فكنا
برضو خدنا المعديه اكلنا اللي بيجولك وانت
بتعدي في المعديه زي ما انتم شايفين كده
ورحنا بورفؤاد الناحيه التانيه شفنا
الفرنش اللي كانت مبنيه وقت بناء قناه
السويس من زمان قوي وبصراحه كنا مبهورين
قوي بالمباني وبالمناظر اللي احنا شفناها
واللاند ماكس ما كناش نعرف فعلا انه في
حاجه زي كده موجوده عندنا وده شجعنا اكتر
انه طيب احنا مدام في لوكيشن زي ده موجود
عندنا واحنا ما نعرفش عنه حاجه دافئه كده
يكون في كتير قوي ما نعرفش عنهم حاجه
وده شجعنا ان احنا بعد كده ندور اكتر ومع
التدوير والمعرفه عرفنا انه في بحيره
الشيخ بس لو انا جيت قلت لك يلا نخرج كفر
يلا نروح كفر الشيخ هنسافر كفر الشيخ ودنه
سيم او ساوند ويلد يقول لك يلا نطلع على
كفر الشيخ طب ما نطلع في مول احنا عارفينه
وبنسافر حته احنا عارفينها يوديني كفر
الشيخ اوكي وده عكسي كان الموقف بتاعنا من
الصور اللي احنا شفناها من الناس هناك
وحبينا ان احنا ننقل الاكس او نشوف الاكس
لاول مره احنا ما كناش عارفين هيكون عامل
ازاي زي بالظبط ما كنا رحنا في بورسعيد بس
مبهرنا قوي
اللي كان هناك طريقه عيشه الناس
وغيرتف بتاعنا كمان عن او ان احنا نروح
مكان تاني او محافظه تانيه انه اتوين جاست
اباوت اللوكيشن زي ما كنا مفكرين في
بورسعيد كمان
كان في الالمنت بتاع انه في لايف ستايل
انه في ناس عايشه هناك يعني بحيره البرلس
الناس عايشه هناك بس على الصيد
والشخلوبه اللي احنا شفنا صورتنا في الاول
خالص دي كانت زمان شادر سمك شادر سمك ده
زي فيش ماركت كان الناس الصيادين بيجيبوا
الاكل السمك بتاعهم يصطادوا ويروح يبيعوه
هناك كل يوم بدري الساعه سته الصبح
ودهم حتى لو رحت هناك هتلاقي فيه بيوت
موجوده مبنيه في وسط البحيره والناس عايشه
وده الحاجه اللي هم بيعملوها دي اللايف
سايكل بتاعتهم هو بيصحى يصطاد بعد كده
يجيب السمك يبيعه وياكل منه كمان بس
خليتنا كمان ان احنا نقفشيات اللايف سائل
بتاعهم ده ونعرف ان في حاجات احنا ما
نعرفهاش عن البلد فدي كانت حاجه بجد مبهره
قوي لينا او غيرت كمان او زودت الديمنشنز
من مجرد ان احنا رايحين بس عشان نشوف مكان
احنا كمان رايحين نشوف ناس ونشوف كمان
جديده واللي حاجه خلتني بجد براود اكتر في
كل مره بنروح مكان جديد وبنكتشف فيه حاجه
جديده
بمجرد
شفناه على الفيسبوك جريده اون لاين سمعنا
انه في مكان او قريه صغننه قوي في الغربيه
القريه دي بتصدر 60% من الياسمين اللي
موجود في العالم
وهنا احنا
بتاعنا اكثر او الانسانتف احنا لما كنا
المره اللي فاتت في كفر الشيخ احنا قلنا
ان احنا كنا مره لير بعد كده زودنا لير
بعد كده زدنا لحاجه تانيه ان احنا لقينا
هنا ان في فاليو اكتر للكوميونتي اللي
احنا رايحين لها دي وهي
التصنيع او الانتاج الياسمين
ودي حاجه شجعتني اكتر ان احنا نروح بس
عشان نوصل هناك دي ماكينات السهله خالص
يعني ما كانت سهله زي ما انتم شايفين كده
مثلا الصور اكشن عشان نوصل للصور دي قعدنا
شهرين كاملين ندور على كونتاكت بس
يستضيفنا في مزرعه ياهوستاس في مزرعه
اللي حصل بالظبط دخلت على جروب سلف بوك
عارف لما تدخل بالضبط مثلا على جروب
كومباوند عايز تعرف مثلا يكون ده بيحصل
فيه ايه او حي معين مثلا همم سكان مصر
الجديده محبي كومباوند مش عارف ايه تلاقي
كده الناس كلها موجوده في جروبس ده اللي
انا عملته عشان خاطر اقدر ريتشارد لاي حد
من هناك ادخل على كل الجروبس على فيسبوك
يا جماعه احنا مجموعه شباب مجموعه طلاب
عايزين نكتشف المنطقه بتاعتكم وحابين ان
انتم تعرفوا حابين ان احنا نعرف الناس
اكثر عنكم وبجد احنا اكس
شهرين لحد ما في حد صاحب مزرعه هناك كلمني
وقال لي ينفع تيجي وظبط لنا
هناك هتبقى عامله ازاي بس برضو لازم
تعرفوا انه هم هناك برضو زي كفر الشيخ بس
اللايف سائل مختلف لان انت هناك اليوم
بيبدا من الساعه اتنين بالليل فاحنا مثلا
لما كنا رايحين في بورسعيد رايحين اي مكان
بنصحى الساعه سته نروح تمانيه نتحرك نروح
هناك هنا احنا كنا بنتحرك من القاهره
الساعه 12 عشان خاطر اقدر اروح هناك لانه
اليوم هناك بيبدا الساعه اتنين بالليل
يجمعوا ياسمين زي ما انتم شايفين كده يروح
على المصنع وبعد كده المصنع من دوره
بيقلبه ويخليه ان هو يتصدر يبقى ان هو
يتصدر ويروح المصانع طبعا زي ما احنا
شايفين في الصور ده حاجه كمان خلتني ان
احنا نعرف اكتر عن فاليو المكان ده ونسيت
اكثر من كده بكثير طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين
في الصور هنا عم فرج من اكتر الناس اللي
كانت سبورتيفلينا لان احنا لما بنروح مكان
جديد وبنكتشفه بالنسبه للناس احنا بنكون
فالي وير د لان انت رايح تصور حاجه هو
بيعملها كل يوم تمام دي حاجه عاديه
بالنسبه له فانت رايح تصوره وفي ناس بتبقى
شويه انت جاي تصورني ليه انت جاي تحط صور
بتاعتي مثلا اونلاين وتخلي الناس مثلا
تضحك عليا او حاجات من كده دي كومنتس اكشن
كنا بنسمعها بس احنا بنقول لهم ان احنا مش
جايين عشان خاطر نعمل كده خالص احنا جايين
نعرف الناس ليكم ونعرف الناس بالفاليوز
والقيم اللي انتم بتعملوها
اكتر اكتر تلاته معلقين معنا
حبينا ان احنا نشرهم بس ده خلينا نفكر ان
احنا
الموضوع مش بس ان احنا بنروح من مكان
لمكان وخلاص كده احنا يا جماعه بنروح
بنكتشف بتاعتنا من اول وجديد بنكتشف
الايدنتي
بتاعتنا
فجيل وراء جيل هيفضل موجود عايز في
المدينه دي فخور بالايدنتيتي بتاعته وعايز
ان هو يكبر فيها اكثر ما يجيش جيل في النص
يقول لك لا انا مش هفضل مكمل هنا وهروح
اقدر محافظه تانيه القاهره او اي محافظه
وده اكشن اللي حصل في اوقات كثيره لانه
الناس مش حاسه ان احنا شايفينهم او ان
احنا مقدرينهم قوي واحنا كل ما بنكتشف في
يوم كل ما بنكتشف اكتر فينا في الايدي
بتاعتنا
اخر حاجه عايز اقولها انه
دي حاجه اللي انا لمستها بنفسي انه